best interview ever
well as the weather heats up it's
important to make sure that your pets
are safe when taking them outside and
joining us with some helpful tips from
pet pal pro is sam dorigio thank you for
being here thank you for having me on
the kids we have friends here tell us
who's here
so these are not actually my kids but
they they come with me when i like to
get the message out about you know pet
safety yes this is virgil waffles and he
wears his own little bandanna that says
virgil waffles and you've got miss
gracie miss gracie and she has an ice
cream sweater her dress on perfect for
summer she's a tripod but like we have
to tell you like she's got three legs
yeah or if you like there's a leg
missing
she's all good look at that face she is
just so happy and relaxed she's a tv
star she's very relaxed today
oh i could just sit here and talk about
them all the time but let's talk about
some safety tips and you know the the
temperature outside is hot but that
pavement is even hotter what are some
things to keep in mind it's brutal so
you know
i mean we've not seen the 80s for a
while but even if it was 80 degrees
you're looking about 130 degrees wow the
asphalt itself you know so you know you
personally wouldn't walk without shoes
on that and you shouldn't do it with
your pets you know one way that you can
do that and get them out without bending
a little feet is to do little boots
little booties but you still need to
pick the time of day okay make sure it's
not too hot and very short walks you
like those
you can have those but very very short
walks you just can't do what you
normally do in cool cooler weather you
know so that's that's one of the tips
another one is lots and lots of water
okay and sometimes it's hard to carry
water for you and the dogs this works
perfectly you squeeze it it fills up wow
i've never seen that before
we can share with our absolutely perfect
that is brilliant yeah it's always kind
of hard you have to bring a bowl and all
the extra stuff and that just makes it
easy it does and another thing that
makes it easy is a collapsible ball that
will attach to your leash
and what you're going to do is you're
going to pop it open oh that's great too
so that's perfect it's easy for walks or
you know if you're going even in the car
or something it's really helpful to have
something like that
you can drink out the bulk dude
a very simple simple way and actually
this works for humans too okay get a
little bandanna soak it in water put it
around the neck
you know it's so easy and you're just
doing everything to be
you know as cautious as you can of
course considering how hot it is and
another thing you could do is dogs are
susceptible to sunburn they just are and
this is called the sun tea and this sun
tea is a 50 factor
so if you've got a hairless dog in
particular they definitely need to be
wearing something to protect their skin
you can also put sunscreen on them they
do burn on their nose as well wow i've
never heard that before so kind of the
things you would do for yourself you
would do for your pets
one way to check that you know when
you're out there you know walking is you
know you can put your hand on the
pavement how about run down the end of
your driveway and try and get the mail
and you'll build it in their feet and
you'll be able to tell whether it's too
healthy about it oh yeah i mean now with
this vegas he you can't even step
outside for a minute so i can only
imagine how it is on their little paws
exactly so don't have the expectation
that you can still do the same walks uh
it's just not going to happen but
they're going to be shorter pick the
right time of day if it's just too hot
any time of day which we know we're
going to get to that point yeah play
with them inside do a little bit of
training get them some enrichment toys
tie them out physically and mentally
don't feel guilty don't feel like i must
take them on a walk because
i feel so bad but if a hot walk is going
to be detrimental to them keep them
inside that there's ways to tire them
out it's so precious
and you know i always want to dress up i
have two siberian huskies and my husband
laughs at me but now it's important for
their help so i need a bandana i need a
little dress you just wait
with your huskies as you know the coats
that they have those coats are there to
keep them cool right so don't be shaving
your huskies down you know some people
do and it's it's like don't take that
natural protection away from them you
got to keep them fluffy thank you so
much for all these tips and things
our friends here
i don't know if i'm giving them back
thank you for all the helpful takes
mercedes i'll send it over to you